mariane pearl bonsoir j'ai 36 ans vous
êtes française veuve de daniel pearl
journaliste au wall street journal qui a
été enlevé et assassiné par les
islamistes il ya presque deux ans à
karachi alors qu'il enquêtait sur les
filières du terrorisme au pakistan
bernard lévy a consacré un livre à votre
mari a le livre s'appelle qui a tué
daniel pearl chez grasset alors
aujourd'hui c'est vous qui publie un
livre ça s'appelle un coeur invaincu la
vie et la mort courageuse de mon mari
daniel pearl édité chez plon
alors vous avez rencontré daniel pearl
votre mari en 1998 dans une fête
vous répondrez vous êtes journaliste à
rfi et lui et au wall street journal
mais basé à londres donc ils circulent
en europe et dans le monde
vous êtes mariés n'ont plus tard c'était
le coup de foudre
on peut dire j'ai rencontré dans une
soirée en face de l'elysée c'était une
soirée d'une amie il est accompagné
d'une jeune femme blonde
je m'étais pas rendu compte à ce moment
là qu'ils étaient avec elle elle faisait
de la lingerie féminine je me souviens
et voilà il est reparti avec elle quand
même et puis ok mais quand même mais on
s'est écrit on s'est écrit là il est
temps l'arabie saoudite à ce moment là
il faisait des erreurs enquête et puis
on s'est écrit on a fini par se voir
oui c'est ça c'est un jour il vous dit
qu'il peut passer à paris en allant à
londres 100 trains arrivent d'espagne au
bon moment donc en fait ils passent ils
voient comment ça se passait là il faut
partir éventuellement si voilà si elle
se trompe de destination il n'a jamais
repris le train pour un assemblage un
petit peu étonnant tous les deux parce
que vous votre père et le fils naturel
d'un diamantaire juifs hollandais vous
dit en parlant lui homosexuels peu
sympathique café l'amour une fois avec
une femme et ça a marché
voilà et votre mère cubaine noir avec un
grand père chinois sérieux melandri et
lui par an juif
sa mère d'irak et son père d'israël
c'est des bonnes bases pour un
journaliste entre scènes de vie
d'ailleurs qu' il était extrêmement
cosmopolite et les journalistes avant
d'être américain avant d'être juif et
c'est un choix vraiment donné voilà
c'est là il avait cette approche là et
c'est comme ça qui est d'ailleurs passé
son temps moyen-orient la plupart du
temps dans les pays musulmans et c'est
comme ça qu'on est parti en inde s'est
passé comme ça par le pakistan alors le
pitch du bouquin c'est simple un cessez
votre vie à karachi du jour du du
kidnapping de votre époux donc daniel
pearl le 23 janvier 2002 jusqu'à votre
départ du pakistan le 27 février 2002
alors c'est pas un livre d' enquête 1
vous me faites pas encore une fois
l'enquète si votre histoire dans la
tente de connaître le sort réservé à
votre à votre mari et puis vous parlez
de vos vies vous parlez de votre amour
vous l'aimiez énormément alors quand le
bouquin commence vous êtes tous les deux
à karachi
vous travaillez vous travaillez ensemble
vous l'accompagnez souvent annoncée
lorsque j'interviens semble beaucoup lui
aussi ma campagne
on était ensemble ensemble mais là bon
ce jour là comme vous êtes enceinte à
l'époque que vous êtes fatigués vous
avez des nausées et vous de laisser
partir tout seul à son rendez-vous ce
jour-là est en cause il ya beaucoup de
concours de circonstances ce genre là
donc moi je ne crois pas trop à l'idée
destin mais c'est vrai que par exemple
des il ya des mesures de sécurité dans
ce genre de pays on prend pas trop de
taxi bon ce jour-là un taxi-be bien il
ya un certain nombre de salles de
concours de circonstances qui bon qui
ont fait que le kidnapping a été
possible et et que moi je sois resté en
fait derrière c'est ça surtout si vous
aviez été avec lui est ce que vous
pensez que les islamistes qui l'ont
assassiné je dirais beaucoup plus que ça
à découper en morceaux après l'avoir
décapité
est ce que vous croyez qu'il l'aurait
fait quand même je pense que oui je
pense que oui je pense pas qu'on a on
est devant des gens qui auraient qui
auraient reculé en fait de valeur de 20
le fait que je sois une femme y aura
suffit aux nordistes comptent arrêter
juifs par exemple même enceinte même
enceinte même enceinte alors daniel
pearl ce matin la part seul il fait une
enquête sur reed le type qui avait pris
l'avion avec les chaussures prennent
d'explosifs l'homme se mêlent explosive
comme on l'a appelé il va rencontrer le
fameux ghillani il a rendez vous avec
omar sheikh dondon lévy parle dans son
bouquin et c'est vrai que c'est omar
sheikh au départ comme il a fait la
london schools of economics et pas
quelqu'un qui dans ton peut se méfier au
départ c'est quelqu'un d'extrêmement
efficace enfin quelqu'un qu'il ya cette
espèce de sac c'est comme une espèce de
terroristes free lance donc je pense
avoir fait représente un petit peu la
nouvelle génération de terroristes et
des gens qui s'associe à des opérations
précisé ce désastre de l'an suite lui au
marché que c'est quelqu'un effectivement
de d3 éduqués qui qui a une vraie
perversité en résidence est à sa façon
de faire par exemple à dany lui envoyer
des emails en disant c'est pas grave si
vous pouvez pas venir la prochaine fois
quand dany a été kidnappée il n'a envoyé
notre hymne à la danse on danse on sa
boîte en disant comment s'est passé
votre rendez vous voyez c'est ce que
c'est quand même voilà vicieux
une approche très vicieuse ontera
pervers la fois avec un budget du génie
malin quoi alors la journée se passe
vous n'arrivez pas à le joindre
ça vous étonne parce que d'habitude vous
dites que vous vous appelez toutes les
90 minutes sur les portes à un système
de sécurité simplement en fait de nous
appeler si nous n'étions pas ensemble de
nous appeler toutes les 90 minutes pour
un simple le soir toujours pas de dany
vous êtes dans un dîner vous vous
éloignez et puis vous commencez à
réciter parce que vous êtes bouddhiste
vous récitez de l'agneau ringler kyo ça
aide
ça m'a aidé ça m'a aidé énormément parce
que effectivement là toutes les choses
qui sont vraiment des valeurs sûres
monsservin énormément quoi ouais donc le
bouddhisme est une valeur sûre
apparemment c'est vrai alors là vous
appelez le consulat américain et on vous
dit que ça peut attendre le lendemain
matin et on l'a on tombe sur un sur un
pion en fait un qui nous dit non mais
peut-être il ya eu d'abus peut-être il
et je sais pas où enfin c'est aura donc
nous dit attendez de matin effectivement
la leader compte c'est difficile oui oui
c'est à dire que vous en faites vous
savez tout de suite que ça peut pas être
un accident de bagnols vous vous doutez
quelque chose de plus grave ou comment
c'est même un petit peu à culpabiliser
en vous disant je n'aurais jamais dû le
laisser partir tout seul n'aurait jamais
dû y aller enfin et c est là vous
appeler les parents de votre mari
d'annie comme vous l'appelez sa mère qui
s'appelle ruth et elle vous dit cette
phrase qu'elle vous le dis qu'à la fin
de l'entretien téléphonique mais vous
vous ressentez qu'elle y pense depuis le
début elle vous dit est ce que quelqu'un
sait que nous sommes juifs
voilà c'était la première première
réaction mais moi aussi quand même c'est
ça ouais d'une zone où bon quand même en
pensant que bon toute cette nuit là on
avait accumulé informations sur les gens
sur la nature des personnes qui
l'avaient qu'il devait rencontrer
on n'était pas rassurés quand même donc
on est quand même après le 11 septembre
on sait que 20 mois toutes les questions
avec al-qaïda et c est donc la pose la
question quand même elle avait raison a
été de savoir qui c'est que d'être un
juif parce que sa mère tout de suite a
repéré deux à trois paires et a repéré
le truc et c'est vrai vous dites qu'au
pakistan il ya une vraie
end et des juifs et vous avez rencontré
un ancien patron qui s'appelle amis de
goules des services secrets pakistanais
jusqu'en 89 qui vous dit que le jour du
wall trade center en fait tous les juifs
ne sont pas allés travailler ce que tu
une espèce de fantasme de grands circulé
sur internet dans les pays arabes mais
bon que les gens croyaient dans leur
ignorance en fait que le mossad avait
organisé toutes ces attaques et que les
4000 juifs qui travaillait au world
trade center n'était pas là ce jour là
ouais voilà donc vous entendez ça de la
bouche d'un dignitaire du but du
canadien qui quand même été à mon ami un
entretien d'une heure avec dany donc ils
avaient des arguments intéressants c'est
quelqu'un de plausible il avait dirigé
les à gaza les services secrets
pakistanais pendant le moment
bon avec les américains etc et puis sur
des qu'il dise qu'il s'agissait des
juifs est plus viable c'était plus bon
c'était plus jeunes c'est plus rationnel
la sécu rationnelle c'est ça alors vous
finissez par recevoir des photos de
votre mari
combien de jours après le jour de
l'enlèvement trois jours trois jours
donc vous recevez des photos qui
confirme effectivement qu'il a été
kidnappé qu'il est donc vivant mais en
même temps qu'il a un bon mental parce
qu'à une photo il a un flingue sur la
tempe et en fait on voit bien la photo
d'ailleurs il y là il a un sourire quoi
malgré ça donc vous vous dites quand
même il et il tient bon quoi ouais je
pense qu'il est dernièrement fait on a
été dans le même état d'esprit dès le
départ à savoir que je pense qu'on a
tous les deux compris exactement là où
on se trouvait et compris ce qu'il
fallait qu'on fasse exactement dont
quand même la première premières
réactions celle à résister à la peur
voyez donc je pensais ce qu'il a fait
tout de suite c'est ce que j'ai fait
tout de suite
et quand on est effectivement j'ai reçu
des photos bon il avait une photo
effectivement où il ya une absolue sur
la tempe et un sourire sur les lèvres
une photo il fera donc ses on vous dit
quand même
je sais ce qu'ils pensent je sais
comment je sais comment ils résistent
ils ses copains moi c'était la même
chose donc j'étais quand même assez
confiant
vous dites en voyant ça finalement on
peut pas s'emparer d'un esprit fort quoi
c'est à dire qu'ils ont beau le tenir
physiquement sous la puissance des armes
son esprit reste reste fort voilà alors
à ce moment là effectivement il ya une
certaine aide internationale qui se met
en place il ya farrakhan le leader de
national islam qui est un mouvement
musulman américain il ya l'émir du qatar
qui était un ami de daniel pearl mohamed
ali
cat stevens chanteur des années 60
reconvertir en dj ben ouais mais d'abord
il absolument et qui s'appelle moossou
fils la maintenance office la voilà et
alors y'a que michael jordan qui refuse
la première son âge dont l'attaché de
presse michael jordan
pas pour des raisons d'image haussariat
enfin bon voilà je vais enlever le livre
ouais ouais ça y est quand même une
mobilisation de ce personnage de jean
les gens sont unis afin se sont réunis à
l'idéal est bon il est innocent c'est
tout le monde le savait mais donc même
les gens qui d'ailleurs qu'ils ont
capturé je pense et c'est vraiment dans
le monde islamique sud et notamment les
gens se sont mobilisés on va envoyer des
beaux messages à l'air d'être très beau
message
bon je pense que là on était quand même
au delà de la communication a fonctionné
et puis arrive la nouvelle de la mort de
d'amis
vous écrivez un cri d'animal quand la
mâchoire métallique du piège se referme
sur la bâtir que quand vous avez la
preuve qu'il est mort voulurent les tuer
parce que j'ai mal parce que ça fait ça
ça fait mal
oui parce qu'on a passé cinq semaines a
en fait à une espèce de résistance
mentale très très très très fort donc et
une réaction comme ça d'abord je mens
évidemment je crie parce que parce qu'il
fallait sortir puis on n'a rien on n'a
rien sorti aucun d'entre nous n'a rien
n'a laissé aucune émotion filtré pendant
plusieurs pendant toutes ces semaines
ensuite je me souviens avoir m emparé
d'un équivalent et savannah comme j'ai
pas commandé à france-amérique et 47 à
44 47 et aussi des réactions comme ça
mais en réalité
quand même quand j'ai les personnes qui
m'ont raconté ce qu'ils ont vu et pour
gagner commente-il comment il est mort
m'ont donné en fait tout de suite ce
d'état et qu'il donne dans la vidéo qui
en fait on lui pose des questions avant
de le tuer et à ce détail en fait
concerner son grand père enfin ce une
rue en israël qui porte le nom de son
grand-père et nager compris que cette
même attitude qui défend qu'il avait
dans les photos il avait conservé jusqu
alors et c'est là que j'ai su que qu'il
fallait je reste debout moi même parce
que saint gein validé en fait sont sa
défiance voilà par rapport aux tendances
alors vous dites évidemment pour vous
apprenez ça vous avez vous frapper la
tête contre les murs de la salle de
bains mais c'est normal que cette
enceinte ça c'est une situation
absolument intenable et et vous dites
mais comment vous savez qu'il est mort
et on vous dit il ya une vidéo et
ensuite vous dites mais enfin il ya vous
avez aucun doute sur sa mort et on vous
dit non il a été décapité quoi ça c est
heureusement je dirais comme vous êtes
bouddhiste vous pensez au cycle de la
vie vous pensez que la mort n'est pas
une fin et que tout ça est cyclique et
ça vous aide aussi à ce moment-là ça
m'aide à ce moment là mais je pense que
c'est surtout l'année bouddhisme en fait
n'a amené tout de suite la clairvoyance
surtout avant tout c'est à dire que ce
n'est pas une vue de l'esprit non plus
quoi sert peut pas dans ces moments là
c'est trop extrêmes donc c'était plus si
vous voulez à ce moment là il ya quand
même quelque chose de très intime qui se
passait et je pense que tu arrives à
maman à ce moment à ce moment là où
j'avais plus peur de la mort d'un bon
donc comme je dis dans le livre il ya
toutes les théories sur bons qui sont
passés avant moi réincarnation paradis
ne sais pas quoi en faire et c est là je
me suis rendu compte que que que à
travers en tuant dany les gens qui
l'avaient tué espérer moi me tuer moi et
puis notre enfant et puis tous les gens
qui s'identifient à lui est la seule
véritable réaction par rapport au
terrorisme c'est pas à la guerre puisque
toute façon sur leur terrain on peut pas
je n'aime pas les combattre
mais c'était c'était c'était du vivant
et de vivre en plus heureuse donc à ce
moment là ça me paraissait quand même
dire impossible mais mais je me suis
relevé je les fais ouais alors
évidemment web et la bière
alors la question pourquoi daniel pearl
at il été assassiné alors pour bernard
henri lévy dans son bouquin il avait
découvert des liens entre les islamistes
et le programme nucléaire pakistanais
est ce que c'est avéré ça
je ne sais pas donc la thèse de bernard
henri lévy est intéressante elle est
possible elle est plausible
maintenant il est quand même aussi
possible qu'on les tue et simplement
parce qu'on voulait décourager tous les
journalistes d'investigation qui était
sur place parce que quand même ça
commençait à devenir délicat parce qu'il
était juif
ça suffit dans ce genre de deux pays ou
parce qu'ils étaient américains
bon je sais pas encore une autre théorie
aussi c'est que un ordinateur bourré de
secret d'al-qaïda avait été trouvée par
les journalistes du wall street journal
et cet ordinateur avait été livrée ce
qui est assez rare d'ailleurs à la cia
et quand daniel pearl votre mari avait
appris ça et il vous dit baby on va
avoir des ennuis quand même donc il
savait quand même que le wall street
journal seraient particulièrement visées
par ces gens là ne serait ce que je vois
ce journal trouve sur cet ordinateur
contenait 1700 dossier avec des vidéos
etc qui reprenaient leurs puces le le
trajet de weeds schwander l'a donc sur
lequel année enquêtait et de votre
journal bon c'est normal si vous voulez
qu'ils ont retrouvé un ordinateur comme
celui là il peut sauver des attaques des
débits bon vous pouvez donner la cia et
pouvait pas le faire rendre public à
l'horizon publié des articles et que
c'est que les claironner ça et vous vous
passez votre temps à prouver aux gens
fin a essayé de dire aux gens vous
n'êtes pas des espions
quand même oui on était en danger de la
raison finalement alors vous êtes vous
dit vous êtes contre la peine de mort
j'imagine et non voilà bouddhiste je
pense que dans le bouddhisme que je
pratique et j'ai déjà lu un texte
souvent fait on disait pour par rapport
aux gens qui fabriqué la bombe nucléaire
que ces gens là méritait la mort donc
par rapport à vendre un chèque par
exemple qui a été condamné à mort en 24
jours pas été exécuté qui est donc ce
procès c'est cette personne là bon je
vais pas vous dire qu'elles méritent de
vivre je vais pas vous dire qu'elle est
excusable il est conscient de ce qu'il
fait en marche est quand même c'est
quelqu'un dedans
on pourrait le mettre en prison à
perpétuité pour un être présente et 8 et
mais je pense que enfin bon pour moi ce
qui se plante est le plus c'était que
bon georges bush par exemple a demandé à
ce que vous voulez alors qu'il soit
extradé aux états unis
bon pour moi ce qui comptait c'est que
le pakistan le met à mort parce que
c'est assez d'une déclaration politique
ouais délicat jours mais un engagement
dans tous les cas l'on vous êtes
favorable à la peine de mort pour omar
sheikh en tous les cas c'est clair mais
quand on lit votre livre il ya un mirage
les miennes arriver à dépasser
vous dites je me bats pour que mes
sentiments soient supérieurs mais
réaction
tu ne peux pas avoir une réaction comme
ça bestiale mais essayer de dépasser
d'en faire une histoire un peu
symbolique quoi la haine en fait c'est
le sera début de la paralysie et la
baleine en fait nan apporte aucune
aucune possibilité d'action d'abord
aucune possibilité d'avenir
bon on a quand même un enfant et en plus
si vous voulez c'était le but recherché
c'est tellement c'est ça le rkc fomenté
la haine créé un à la surface entre les
civilisations
le premier la première résistance et
celle ci en fait elle a peur puis line
ouais c'est je ne fais que résister au
terrorisme j'essaie de transformer le
caler leur organisme
j'adore le bouder nous essaierons mais
le calvaire de votre mari en victoire
c'est ça non lui la victoire ville là
c'était mais mais mais si mais si moi je
suis si lui lui la gagne et je pense
vraiment quoi mais si moi je suis quand
même là pour valider sa victoire c'est à
dire notre enfant à travers un jeu fait
quoi c'est ça vous n'avez pas perdu le
sourire dany vous disais toujours nous
allons devenir chauve gros et vieux mais
tu n'as pas le droit de perdre ce
sourire et voulait pas perdu malgré tout
les épreuves que vous affrontez depuis
alors effectivement on parle de cet
enfant quand dany a été assassiné vous
étiez enceinte
il s'appelle adam il a aujourd'hui 17
mois et vous dites en barrant lui c'est
le débit universel c'est vrai il a tous
les sens mélanger je crois que c'est
vraiment un
il a très bien si vous n'aviez pas été
enceintes à la mort de daniel pearl est
ce que vous seriez suicider j'y pense
mais je me serais suicidé je pense que
j'aurais été j'aurais fait quelque chose
qui fait
je me serais pas tuer moi même je pense
que j'aurai gens là peut-être je sais
pas fait quelque chose c'est facile d'en
face où il ya déjà beaucoup d'armes dans
le coin j'en fais quelque chose de tête
de désespérer peut-être un geste
désespéré jeu
bon je sais pas si c'est plus mon
histoire là c'est pas tant que ça oui
c'est bien vous donner un beau fixe
merci le coup marianne te remercie
[Musique]
et la mort pour ajustement m'arrive
daniel peur
cet été chez plon et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de linars dit tu es abonné
vous y mettez un peu de bleu